[Music]
why don't we go next where where to even
go let's go to roy from south jersey roy
welcome to the program
uh good afternoon
welcome what's on your mind
um i just wanted to say that um the alex
jones conspiracy about uh vlad the
impaler and all that stuff yeah um from
a historical standpoint it doesn't make
any sense uh the house that he was
talking about wasn't founded for another
400 years vlad the impaler was not the
progenitor of all european dynasties etc
so from a historical standpoint it makes
no sense yeah i got an email about that
let me see if i can even find it it was
pretty funny
uh from someone who said
oh wait oh it was from you you're this
is just you emailed in
yeah you had a bunch of interesting
things where you explained that like
that the the the family he's saying is
the oldest family isn't and he's got the
lineages wrong and the funny thing is
like any normal person would listen to
that and know it doesn't make any sense
but then as you did when you actually
look into the specifics it makes even
less sense
right
um now i wanted to ask you a question
i've been called a monster for this okay
i shower with my glasses on um
am i a monster for that that i have
never heard of that ever i've never
heard of anyone doing that i will
sometimes shower with my contacts on and
i know that that's controversial and
people will say oh sir you could get a
crazy infection from that um i mean i've
been doing it off and on for you know of
20 years
but um
gla i have never heard of anyone
showering with glasses on how do don't
they get all steamed up
well yeah but then i'll just you know
wipe them off with my towel and then
i'll be fine wait you're bringing a
towel into the shower
well it'll be hanging out outside of it
and then i can just you know tuck my
head out and wash them off for a second
so how many times do you have to do that
during your typical shower
yeah like four or five so you're telling
me that what you do is you wear glasses
during the shower hang a towel outside
and then five times per shower lean out
to wipe them
that's correct wouldn't it be easier
just to take them off
um
probably yeah i've been doing it all my
life you know are you nearsighted
uh i'm farsighted oh so these are
reading glasses
yeah oh interesting and you need you
feel like you need those to shower
um i mean i don't want to like slip on
something or fall or whatever so
i kind of like feel more comfortable
with them on well listen safety is our
number one priority if that's what you
need to feel safe but it is certainly
unorthodox i will i will leave it there
roy
all right thank you for your uh
assessment you're still allowed in the
audience though it's not that crazy okay
yeah fair all right roy from south
jersey wow showering with glasses on
i've never heard of it never never heard
of it very interesting
let's go next to
now i'm gonna get this right this time
let's go to
elias
from texas did i get it right this time
so what's going on
oh okay um it seems like in the u.s the
folks that are concerned about climate
change are in the minority
when it comes to affecting public policy
how can we overcome the overwhelming
political odds
to pass meaningful legislation and how
can we get how can we do it quick quick
enough to hopefully avoid the worst
effects of climate change that are
predicted i don't know that i agree with
the premise now let's let's see if we
can clarify it you're saying
most of the general public doesn't want
to do anything about climate change or
most of our elected officials don't i
think i think elected officials is like
all the money that that comes from oil
companies and rights all of that so
here's the thing
most of the pop of the population does
want to do something about climate
change so the solution is
we need this is a crazy radical idea we
need to elect people
who will do the will of the voters and i
know it's like so point the problem of
course is between gerrymandering and
campaign finance and super pacs yeah and
all of these other voter suppression
techniques and all of it
we are not actually getting elected
officials that represent the will of the
people think about abortion right the
the will of the people is overwhelmingly
that abortion be legal in most cases if
you look at the senate that's not the
view in the senate of the hundred
senators we've got a real problem there
we don't really have representation
right is there okay if i follow up with
another question please elias go ahead
how do you feel about bringing a child
into this world knowing that you're
going to be saddling them with the
burden of living on a on an un
inhabitable planet yeah so here's the
deal with that
um
for me
i believe that only people are going to
solve the problems that we have and i
believe they are solvable
and so i know a lot of people have taken
this approach of i would never have a
kid because
the country the country's screwed the
planet screwed the species whatever
i think that if we don't
bring some people in who maybe could be
problem solvers we have no shot you miss
a hundred percent of the shots you don't
take
uh yeah and so i wanna have a shot at it
and so i want to bring someone in who
maybe could be someone that finds
solutions
yeah
wow thank you so much david all right
thank you for saying my my name's my
name correctly too that's my pleasure
thank you for the call
are very good there is elias